قالت الصحافه العبريه انه بسبب الحرب على
غزه فقد استوردت اسرائيل 500 طن من
الطماطم من الاردن في اسبوع واحد لتعويض
النقص طبعا الذي
حدث من خفض
كميات المستورده من الخضروات والفواكه من
تركيا قانون حمايه المستهلك اصبح يلزم
التجار في اسرائيل بتحديد بلد المنشا
للسلع الغذائيه بهدف توفير الشفافيه
للمستهلكين الذين لا يرغبون في شراء بضائع
من الدول المعاديه لاسرائيل بعد هذا
القرار تداول الاسرائيليون صورا تظهر
خضروات اردنيه في الاسواق طماطم من انتاج
الاردن خيار من انتاج الاردن وانتشرت هذه
الصور طبعا في الاردن واثارت ضجه كبيره
لانها تكشف اسماء الشركات الاردنيه
المصدره الى
اسرائيل طبعا هناك غضب واستهجان في الشارع
الاردني خرج العشرات من المتظاهرين بمحيط
سفاره الاسرائيليه بالعاصمه عمان ضد تصدير
الخضروات الى اسرائيل شاهدوا يحكى عنا
مكان يحكى ان كن يا مكان الخضره طلعت من
عمان الخضره طلعت من عمان الخضره طلعت من
عمان الخضره طلعت من عمان كانن ارسلتها
لغزه كان ارسلتها لغزه كرنا ارسلتها لغزه
فكرنا ارسلتها لغزه حت عمل الكيان طلع
داعم للكيان طلع الداعم للكيان طلع داعم
للكيان الجمعيه الاردنيه لمصدري ومنتجي
الخضار والفواكه اصدرت بيانا قالت فيه
انها تستنكر ما تناقلته وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي بخصوص تصدير الخضار الى الكيان
الصهيوني من احد اعضاء الهيئه العامه وهو
فاقد لعضويته منذ عام
2022 تؤكد الجمعيه ان اعضائها ملتزمون
بعدم تصدير الم المتجات الزراعيه الى
الكيان الصهيوني طبعا بين الاردن واسرائيل
معاهده سلام وتنص على ضروره التعاون
الاقتصادي بين الطرفين لكن وزير الزراعه
الاردني خالد حنيفات علق على هذا الموضوع
في لقاء تلفزيوني
يقول بلا ادنى شك هناك تصدير للجانب
الاسرائيلي منذ ما يزيد عن 30 عام وهناك
تجار لديهم عقود مع الجانب الاسرائيلي
اضافه الى تصدير الى الضفه الغربيه واضافه
الى ترانزيت عبر ميناء حيفا هذه ثلاث
مسارات حقيقه لا يوجد مكنه قانونيه تمنع
هذا التاجر او المستثمر من تصدير لدى
وزاره الزراعه فقط نقول لهم في ظل الظرف
الحالي انه استع على حالكم شوي
بس اذا استحوا على حالكم شوي حسب تعبير
الوزير كيف علقتم انتم على تصدير الخضروات
الاردنيه الى اسرائيل بسام عوض قال في
تغريدته سعر كيلو الخيار بعمان وصل بدينار
على بالنا الصقيع هو السبب ما ندري ان
قاعه وجوه بعض التجار والمصدرين هي السبب
محمد احمد قاللك تطلع الشركات تنفي طيب
وتجيب بيانات التصدير انهم صدروهم للضفه
بس ما راح يقدروا لانهم غاطسين غطص باحضان
الكيان طلال السكري يقول لك يعني اذا
شركه بطنها اجرا بتحكي كل الاردن هيك نعرف
انه في بعض الخونه ل فلسطين باعوا هم
للاحتلال هل يجوز القول ان كل فلسطين
خائنه لا قدر الله نور تقول معاهده السلام
والتطبيع موجوده والكل عارف انه في بضائع
وتجاره مباشره بين البلدين من قبل حرب غزه
ليش هلا اننا في كل اللي في ايدينا نقاطع
بضائع الاحتلال والشركات اللي بتتعامل معه
النعمان يقول في تغريدته اللي بيبيع بيع
بضاعه للعدو واللي بوصلها بشاحنات وغيرها
واللي بيمشي الاجراءات كيف ما بيعتبر حاله
خائن لولا هالاشكال كان زمان الكيان زائل
على كل حال وزير السياحه الاردني مكرم
القيسي تحدث قبل اسبوع عن الاضرار التي
سببتها حملات المقاطعه من الشعب الاردني
نستمع المقاطعه يا سيدي المتاثرين تقريبا
12 الى 15000 اردني واردنيه يعملون في بعض
المؤسسات التي تمت مقاطعتها طبعا مثل ما
حكى دوله الرئيس في اكثر من من مجال بان
هذا عباره عن حريه شخصيه
وتعبير مكفول للجميع وحق لكن انت سالتني
عن لغه الارقام وانا بجاوبك نعم سيكون
هنالك تاثير سلبي على ابنائنا وبناتنا من
من جراء هذه المقاطعه
لبعض
المؤسسات